we're back here on the lobby and so our
video games it's January 2015 that some
video games coming out this year did you
know that we're going to talk about some
of the best ones that are coming out or
what we think will be the best ones I
was a great transition was really good
we're back in so our video feeds back I
hope I find it after a brief hiatus
they're back in a couple of weeks yeah
exactly we're not quite yet tomorrow is
a yeah I'm sorry next week h1z1 that's
the first dozen that started the big
ones it's a black comment yet no wow I
thought splatoon was coming out I was
spending like all the essay saying don't
worry guys spittoons at in January
spittoons out in like marches why are
making all this platoon yeah what cuz
it's cuz i bought that time I've become
that guy now I got a wii u and i can't
[ __ ] shut up hey you got you guys
seen this with mario kart yeah it's
really cool it's really good it's all
your favorite Mario people but they
drive cars no big deal to put her they
put a they put the Dillon's got pink or
peach yeah my favorite I want to talk to
you about the order sir okay we went to
add PlayStation experience ya doma whoa
the x.x bach was there yeah is great so
why not go busting Shuhei your sheet at
the card game when the min surprised
he's having a super time force so
anything's possible right and yeah so
one of the game said that's coming out
this year pretty soon actually is the
order dub you were eighteen sixty six
yeah nope no 1886 1886 yep should know
that knew i was born 100 and i have like
real grave concerns about this game i
think a lot to be concerned about it's
super like from what I've played it's
very quick time heavy like I think more
so than what comes across to people sure
what do you use what do you think of it
cuz you're kind of a more in the
positive side i started with like oh
this game's gonna be the common saw
right he came back was like it does not
run well do not be excited like what
ready at Dawn's great right so like
right there i'm at rock bottom on my bed
rock on the expectations and then every
so often it creeps up because somebody
come back and look at this Avenue I
thought the where we'll fight they show
to d3 was cool and so then they actually
sit down and play it I had problems i
think the cameras too tight I couldn't
find things like super like you just
like take a left kind of thing you know
you're like running is like well we're
out of advanced and I'm running around
the map trying to find it and then
eventually I saw it okay um it seems
like it'll be cool narrative you don't
mean like I like the setting i like what
they're doing it's beautiful I do I
think
gonna change revolutionize gaming anyway
now you know me like it's goofy I don't
know the QuickTime thing doesn't bog me
down in terms of if it's fun to get
through then that's that's my big
question right is they show these
awesome set pieces you know you're
coming down the Hindenburg pretty much
whatever and get in there and the
stealth kills when they were working or
really cool as get discovered like well
this sucks because when you get
discovered it literally shows an
animation of you getting in the hedge
yeah like there's no there's no even
like gameplay happening there
essentially it's like a new story analog
like kill him or don't and then reset
it's like it's somewhere between a
telltale Game yeah my gears of war
there's like a Brita break in there yeah
it's like a resident evil five steampunk
victorian style yeah so we're trying to
say you try to sell me other than Ozzy I
don't know like real racist or something
don't say resin will fire trying to sell
a game uh no I think you know I I saw
the order back in just about a year ago
when they go behind closed doors okay
and I came back when wrote my piece and
I'm like this games like Greg's am like
this games in really bad shape you know
and you know because they had revealed
it at the e3 before and then at Gamescom
they basically just show like a tech
demo with again kind of running I
remember being frustrated because even
with my interview they to show the trail
where the first time like it behind
closed door that my already seen this
and I had to spend my time being like is
it a third-person shooter or
first-person shooter like it's a
third-person Jeremiah is it is it some
even get to and you're like yeah I'm
like and I'm like and there are times up
and I'm like all right yeah you know
like like in other in other words they
could have just shown the game yeah but
i think that the order is an interesting
kind of case study and the fact that the
game was in poor shape when i saw it and
a lot of people are mad at me for saying
that and then they saw it when they
release the videos and they saw the
theme was chugging and just didn't seem
that good and then every time we've seen
it since then it's gotten better and
better and improved like that the extra
time they got to finish the game i think
is going to pay off I thought when we
played a PSX for like 40 minutes
whatever that it was a lot of fun I
don't think it's gonna like Greg tiling
it's a game changer on these games gonna
be like amazing I just uh I'm excited
about it and I think the thing that
people need to walk away from it
thinking is that the game is incredibly
cinematic like yeah i think the
production value of the game is super
hot looks incredible it does and the
voice acting is awesome i think the
story is really interesting the fuse
of you know the guys over there really
obsessed with alternate history which
one I am too and I think that the fusion
of things that should be in eighteen
eighty six but really warrant like like
a Zeppelin which doesn't belong there it
makes sense because they've done such a
nice job of making that world so I think
everything surrounding the anyway it's
pretty good whether or not the game pans
out goodness me see what does it
actually release februari yeah sick
sleeping totally forgotten by the end of
the year but I don't talking about up in
the end of the year the the interesting
thing are our friend Vince over a gene
pointed out on the beyond at PSX was the
fact that his concern is that from what
they've shown there's no rhythm to the
gameplay yeah right you have we the part
we played where we infiltrate the
Zeppelin sure then there's this weird on
Rails running from the werewolf you're
shooting at him then there's the other
and it's just like what is this game and
there's every segment even though its
cinematic you get dropped into is it
going to be you have to get a new
tutorial on what you're doing and how
you're doing it because every one of
them has been that yeah exactly we'll
see we're not that were your main
concern I my main concern is that as the
areas that in which it looks like
there's like open gameplay like for
instance that stealth all right I think
you can show down on a trailer and it
looks like one game you're sitting there
playing it it's actually is totally
different one so I think it's more of a
kind of a perception thing I don't think
it's perhaps a bad game but I wonder if
it's not oh people kind of game it is
yeah the mat another game to slipped
into 2015 The Witcher it's a time april
nineteen to the third game of any you
guys play the old ones cuz i know i
don't wait for this one and I've never
touched about the same way and that's
let's move yeah yeah that's the thing is
like I it takes I don't fantasy is
always hard for me to get into this is
my fantasy stuff and every trailer
they've shown in all the combat they've
shown like all right this I think I'm
gonna get into this one and actually
really dig it like I like Skyrim right
yeah those standout games were something
different about it jumps in but yeah I
feel like such a hack saying nobody
can't wait for Witcher 3 oh my god never
played what you wanted to I don't know I
mean I hear they're really complicated
and really dense but that's what's so
exciting so yeah sounds great yeah the
witcher 2 definitely i played about
sixty percent of it okay like it got to
the point where i just said you got to
put a lot of energy into it to get out
you know from combat and stuff like that
and sort of to get to the point where I
felt proficient but you know it's also
pretty tough but soon nothing that can
feed you that can come back at you and
hit the point where I was like little
low energy something else came along I
want to play it but what
fascinates me in what is so wonderful
about the witcher is the world yeah and
I didn't sort of I didn't play the
witcher 2 because everyone was really
raving about it I wasn't excited to play
because of that it was cuz i have a
polish friend over he was read all the
witcher books and is always telling me
about like how this is like this such a
this crazy like half fairy tale half
medieval had half magical just but like
totally vulgar and like an adult like
whole world it was just so intriguing to
me and i think the game is really
replicate that really well and it you
know you go see a dwarf in The Witcher
and it's not like a dwarf in the lord of
the ring yeah there's like re my hearty
under the mountain folk they are like
dropping f-bombs and like down at the
whorehouse all day like just like this
it just busts those sort of genre
conventions all over the place and it
makes it feel fresh even if you're not
kind of that normal fantasy aficionado
yeah at two games i guess that are
coming as in relatively quick succession
and q1 at least and when we've only seen
just recently uncharted for thieves and
hopefully coming at this year they say
2015 yeah we'll see yeah I that was my
predictions I don't think it actually
hits in 20 15 a game informer had the
it's the upper februari yeah they put a
little video today on the site as well
sort of explaining that one of the
things that came at a PSX I guess so
people were like okay they've learned
some lessons from the last of us perhaps
the tone of of uncharted is going to
shift in that direction yeah it wasn't
just you shooting dozens and dozens of
people like you know me was trying to
like on armed people on one not that
section could have been you shooting
dozens and exactly what is returning out
of your AK and at the end of that
excited for for yeah yes we're big on
charted fans here uncharted 3 4 life
perfect 10 I don't care who says yeah I
mean we're both in the candy on Charlie
threes better than to camp which is a
weird place yeah but uh oh yeah spectre
ii uh nice [ __ ] tubes but Matthews
probably you're not crazy not good okay
good I'm glad we have the bold that both
of us showed you share the same thing
which is that they're both awesome yeah
like front to back and you know Drake's
a special character I think I think that
no dogs clearly a very special studio I
would often say that they've shown that
at least right now they're the best
studio in the world and you know the
last one I gave a ten to Greg Gabe
uncharted 3 of 10 although people felt
similarly I think to those games
especially the last of us they have a
lot to live up to the exciting thing
about this is that even though Amy's
gone
who I think is probably the heart and
soul of the series yeah and these are
obviously her characters you know Neil
and Bruce are very astute game designers
race to producers of games you know they
were very responsible for uncharted 2
success which people forget you know
they made uncharted two that made the
last of us while uncharted 3 guys we're
working on a chart 3 in uncharted 4 so I
think there's every reason to be excited
about it Gregory says I was elbowing him
and his ribs the entire time I guess I
would you have to see in this he kept
saying yeah well that was the other but
yeah I mean the game looks amazing
that's what I keep talking about is the
fact that as a huge uncharted fan it I'm
sure they're gonna figure out a better
way to say it but it because it looks
like non-stop action it looks like no
animations safe yeah cuz in the old days
right you grab somebody throw him over
the cliff and you to watch him fall
where's this when you grab the guy throw
him and then he grabs on you're laying
here to fight him off and like i'ma
choke this guy he pulls out his gun and
now you're frantically trying to get
away it's like there's not even those
little moments of rest they want
everything to be going in action
oriented the series I want uncharted to
learn from is not the last of us though
I wanted to learn from tomb raider yeah
most recent one yeah that I think the
way that that did exploration and the
way that it felt like I was in this wild
place like trying to figure it out like
uncharted you know for all its virtues
it you're on a path yeah right and so
I'd love to see Nathan Drake trying to
like you're trying to figure it out
you're in a bigger space you got a
little more freedom there's a little bit
more to do than just like go to the
place go to the place and then look for
Shaunie's and also the ways where this
possible way that death is handled in
Tomb Raider mmm like jeans when you when
you like die environmentally in that is
yeah and I limbs through your mouth my
day and then you just like and then you
watch yeah it doesn't cut away when the
tree limb goes through your mouth yeah
yeah
I kind of want you know if they take a
grittier tone yeah like you're saying
from last of us I'd like to see that yet
come from the tomb raider as well yeah I
hope that the you know we were talking
about this not too long ago in the sense
that I hope that they don't take the
tone obviously from the last of us I
mean I think why people are scared of
that I like the Pope you like kind of
like ridiculousness of uncharted and as
characters are very funny there's a
comedic undertone to this game these
games i think is a little understated my
personal opinions that I hope they kind
of don't change the formula like no
weapon upgrades no non-linearity not
like it's just supposed to be an action
movie it is what it is elements mixed in
exactly like that you know i don't know
crafting i know that just like no co-op
oh I feel like it's inevitable well I
mean they did in the multiplayer mode
before yeah i multiply that's there but
I wonder you know better than his
brother yeah yeah yeah exactly Jesus
Christ you're scaring me now um but yeah
I think I think there's every reason to
be optimistic about the game I think
that there's reasons to be pessimistic
that it comes out this year but
hopefully they make it because I mean
the beauty is that unch our sony ones
all these studios most of them are not
they're not none of them are dormant
it's just we don't know what they're
doing yeah and so that is supposed to be
the fall slated game so you hope that
they don't run into a similar problem
that they did last year where the order
was supposed to be their fall flagship
and they had to get push and then drive
club was the game that no one really was
interested in the beginning with her
life people weren't and then they
certainly weren't when it came out
exactly so yeah there's a lot to be
there's a lot of known around that
window one of the great things about
charter was that they showed us this
massive chunk of game play a game that's
coming out this year from remedy I feel
like quantum break is a game we actually
haven't seen a lot of even though
they've shown like snippets I the
gamescom was the first time we got you
see it in in in in action are you
looking forward to it I love max payne
exactly and i love Alan way yeah but I I
haven't connected to this one yet see
their studio that knows what they're
doing in there almost on that list of
people like you say remic okay cool I
can't wait to see what you doin like
sure that I'd love to see more gameplay
but I'm the trailers are awesome would
like the pieces of glass spinning around
here actually see the gameplay part of
it they I I believe in remedy I believe
like I I'd love to see more but then in
the same breath maybe I know cuz i
believe i'm already what I care yes get
it out you know how many games are
ruined by trailer after show after
children
remember this partner in this part I ok
let's see I what I'm more fascinated
with is how the TV aspect plays into it
yes does it still as well because when
that when Mattrick was in charge that
was the the drum they were running on
like it's clearly not the case anymore
well if they dialed it back but I mean
they're so they've clarified i think is
the big thing saying that the episodes
are on the disk right like i think for
most of us were thinking we'd have to
play in sync with it when it's coming
out because they were pushing xbox one
entertainment stuff like that another
like it's all there's there you do your
thing then you see from that perspective
it's like okay that sounds neat yeah but
it just sounds also like a cutscene my
worry I hope that that's something that
they actually are interested in doing
themselves and wasn't just sure I is it
a micro share saying yeah you know like
the sort of Ubisoft co-op stuff excited
looking forward to it at all yeah I
think quantum break looks awesome I
think it's you know with alan wake's
mystique late in the xbox 360's life so
yeah i think people are really
interested in what these guys are going
to do next I agree with Greg the town at
that studio is really really high so I
think that game's gonna be really
promising I'm just more interested in
there being more you know I like that
there are more xbox one exclusives
generally it's most of 360 where they
had their there you know flagships and
very little else it was the difference I
think maker between the way xboxes
perceived the way PlayStation is
perceived yeah they have halo and gears
which are bigger than everything with
them Sony's like what we have smaller
games that are out every month and so it
seems like xbox is actually announcing
more exclusives which i think is
actually exciting generally beyond just
wanna break up yeah yeah yeah and and
that there's loads of games coming out
in 2015 but the last one I want to talk
about today at Chris you're intimately
familiar with februari at some stage
we're gonna see evolve oh yeah finally
yeah beta on xbox one like next week or
weekends I think anyways I'm super into
that game it's we've had a chance to
play it in the office a couple times and
there's like the lingering question like
I think no doubt one like you play a
match you can see or you watch a match
at PAX on the big screen you see how
this game can create just incredibly
exciting tense things where you know get
four people bonding together or like the
sheer joy of tearing everyone up as a
monster it's the longevity question
which is going to be really interesting
because they have an unlock progression
you know you're going to have to unlock
all the different hunters all the
different monsters as you play and
they've talked only of only lately about
some different modes
but what do you guys think I mean have
you gotten a chance to play evolve it
all I haven't because fundamentally
we're talking about evolve like the very
premise of evolved to me is like I don't
want to do this because play left 4 dead
a little bit but again it's it's like I
don't I would rather just put in a game
and just play about myself this is so to
the master here because it's basically
you're playing of this multiplayer game
that's a co-op game but you don't have
to cooperate with anybody you don't have
to hear anybody talk it might as well
just be NPCs for all the interaction
that's true it's a great that's a great
point it's just like what we won't you
know cuz people are and I general really
banging the drum on this one is well
they're really into it in and just
knowing the premise of I was just like
as you know I'd rather place shovel
knight or something it's one of those
games that I play and I'm in the moment
and I'm having so much fun with it I'm
like I love being the master this is
great Baba and then I stopped and I come
back to wherever tell somebody I like it
a lot and then weeks go by and I find
myself not saying god I can't wait to
play more evolved but then I get to an
event I do play Bob annoying this is
great so like longevity is the big thing
for me to is in terms of is gonna be
something where it's like mario kart
where I've one amazing weekend with it
and then just like kind of forget about
it or is it going to be that I want to
get back in and level up and do this I'm
having answer and also how much of that
is the game design itself sort of
reinforced not bringing you back giving
you new stuff to discover and how much
of it is the time in your life when it
comes out and like what your gaming
appetites are and yeah who's available
who else among your friends gets it like
I feel like that's the other thing with
these cooperative games is even if you
are into them even if you are yeah let's
all get together like I'd love to play
that it there's so many other factors in
terms of your own circumstance that can
conspire to maybe make that just not ya
esta can be I think then putting it in
February like as early as possible is
really good it reminds me of burnout
paradise which is ago but everyone was
playing and people who don't play
driving games you were playing because
it came out in a January when there was
nothing else to play at everyone was
like an event almost so yeah perhaps the
same will be true of evolved so my great
games comment 2015 thanks very much for
coming on talk to us about at that I'm
much more